Good morning Hank; it's Monday!
Goedemorgen Hank; het is Maandag!
Hank, that amazing historic building behind
those Nerdfighters... is a post office.
Hank, today's video comes to you in five parts.
By the way, I had to put the puff on vacation
because I'm getting ready for the very fancy
Venice Biennale. I also had to by a couple
suits. Nerdfighters, do you like this shirt/jacket
combo? Because if you do, I will wear it at
a party, but if you don't, I won't.
Right, that wasn't part one, that was just
a preface. Part one: the unicorn.
So over the last month of living in Amsterdam
I have repeatedly had to use Google Translate
to translate documents from Dutch into English,
and even though it's not a perfect tool, ovbiously,
you usually get a sense of what people mean
and so you're able to be at the right places
at the right time or whatever.
So two nights ago I had dinner with my Dutch
translator Eli and some publishing people,
and in the document describing that dinner
it was just, you know, a list of who was going
to be there, and then the last sentence of
the paragraph was this, which Google translated:
"We do not know which of them will eat the
Unicorn." And I was like "This is going to
be some dinner," because basically Hank, there
are only three categories of dinners. There
are dinners where there will be no unicorns
served, dinners where you know who will eat
the unicorn, and then there are the dinners
where you don't find out who is eating the
unicorn until you get there.
Anyway, Hank, when we got to the dinner I
immediately volunteered to eat the unicorn.
I mean, first off I know that unicorn blood
is restorative, and secondly I hate unicorns
because the fact that their blood is restorative
is the reason that Voldemort was able to,
you know, kill so many nice wizards. But it
turns out it wasn't on the menu; I ended up
having the sea bass, which was also very good.
Part two: Gus, illustrated by Suzanne Van
Leir. Hank, as I'm sure you recall, when the
Yeti was pregnant with Henry, Nerdfighteria
made me illustrations of my favorite out-of-print
picture book so that I could read "Gus is
a Bug" to Henry. But Suzanne went the extra
mile, turning her illustrations for "Gus is
a Bug" into an actual book that Henry loves!
And by loves, I mean chews on. I just thought
that was amazing, Hank.
Part three: spoilers. So you will notice that
when I was talking about the unicorn blood
I did not say which wizards Voldemort kills.
Hank, I've often said over the years that
I don't believe in spoilers, but, to borrow
a phrase from President Obama, my position
on spoilers is evolving. Specifically it has
evolved from not believing in them... to believing
in them.
This positional evolution has happened because
my new book is quite spoilable, and I realized
that I don't want it spoiled for readers,
so like nine months in advance, I am going
to begin asking you and Nerdfighteria: please
don't spoil the book. We will work hard to
create safe spoilery places, and then there
will be the big, unblemished, unspoiled world
outside, yeah?
By the way, Hank, I've started saying that
because people say that here, yeah?
Part four: punishments. Hank, we still haven't
decided on punishments; we need to do that
this week... yeah?
Part five: Tumblr. Hank, you and I have both
been fans of the Tumblr "Eff Yeah Nerdfighters"
-- link in the dooblydoo -- for many years,
but it wasn't until earlier this month that
we both got Tumblrs. We got them on the same
day. It's very cute how we do things on the
same day. It's almost as if we're brothers,
you know, who really l-lo-li-like each other.
Hank, Tumblr seems to be the number one destination
to find Nerdfighter jokes and Looking for
Alaska quotations and DFTBA tattoos and Nerdfightastic
Google investigations and Pizza John/Looking
for Alaska jokes and entire websites devoted
to Humpy Hank. Hank, the Yeti is very amused
by Humpy Hanks, but when she saw the one where
you hump me, she said "It's gone too far".
Anyway Nerdfighters, if you're on Tumblr you
should definitely follow Eff Yeah Nerdfighters.
You can also follow Hank; he's at edwardspoonhands,
which in my opinion is the most under appreciated
Hank song.
And in my continuing attempts to profit from
the bounty of the ocean, you can find me at
fishingboatproceeds.tumblr.com.
Hank, don't forget to be awesome; you'll see
more from Bruges on Friday, but first, I'll
see you on Wednesday.